beginnen wir mit Herrn Mölling wir sehen
wie Soldaten offenbar eine Zivilperson
erschießen wir hören von diversen
Verbrechen gegen die Zivilbevölkerung
Städte werden offenbar zerstört völlig
und eingeschlossen quasi ausgehungert
welche militärische Strategie steckt
dahinter
ja man mag kaum von einer militärischen
Strategie aus der aus der westlichen
Perspektive reden und hier geht's quasi
darum
Gewalt und Gewaltexzesse als als
schreckenmittel zu benutzen auf der
einen Seite möglicherweise geht es aber
auch wirklich um reine Brutalität in
diesem Zusammenhang das ist leider
nichts neues es ist wichtig für uns die
Kategorie Völkerrecht und
Kriegsverbrechen hochzuhalten
es muss uns aber auch klar sein dass die
russische Armee sowohl von ihrer
politischen Spitze also im russischen
Präsidenten bis runter auf die untersten
Ebenen von dieser Kategorie
offensichtlich überhaupt nichts hält so
dass wir darauf gefasst sein dürfen dass
wir den nächsten zwei Wochen noch mehr
dieser schrecklichen Bilder sehen werden
Frau Sasse auf der anderen Seite gibt es
aber auch das haben wir gerade gesehen
Proteste gegen diesen Krieg und eben
eine andere Lesart auch in Russland sind
das ihrer Meinung nach Einzelaktionen
oder bewegt sich da doch etwas
ich denke es bewegt sich etwas aber es
wird nicht direkt auf das
Kriegsgeschehen und die wachsende
Brutalität die wir sehen einen direkten
Einfluss nehmen können es sind Prozesse
in der Gesellschaft in Russland im Gange
und die können meines Erachtens auch das
Land mittelfristig längerfristig
verändern aber wie gesagt jetzt ist ein
Kristallisationspunkt für diese
verschiedenen Proteste zu sehen aber sie
werden das Kriegsgeschehen momentan kaum
beeinflussen können möwling wie sicher
kann sich denn Putin sein dass er diese
Art des Krieges so weiterführen kann
denn wenn sich nur mittel oder
langfristig etwas ändert dann sieht das
ja so aus als könnte er quasi mit dieser
Strategie weitermachen
also er kann möglicherweise damit
weitermachen die Frage ist ob er seine
politischen Ziele erreicht die er gerade
versucht mit militärischen Mitteln
durchzusetzen also denn er hat ja ganz
klar gesagt was er eigentlich erreichen
will ob er das damit erreichen kann ist
die Frage müssen damit rechnen dass die
russischen Streitkräfte in einem bis
zwei Wochen quasi komplett zum
Stillstand gekommen sind und dann
eigentlich nichts mehr weitermachen
können und dann läuft die Uhr noch
stärker gegen Putin weil keine
Fortschritte mehr zu erzielen sind die
Sanktionen immer stärker greifen und die
Menschen die ihn an der Macht halten die
Frage stellen okay erreichen wir noch
irgendwas mit diesem Präsidenten oder
möglicherweise besser ohne ihn jetzt
sagen sie in zwei Wochen könnte dann
Stillstand stattfinden wie kommen Sie
darauf woran machen Sie das fest wir
sehen dass die russischen Streitkräfte
immer stärker verschleißen das ist
normal in solchen Gefechten und an
irgendeinem Punkt müssen Sie die
Streitkräfte wieder rekrutieren oder
neue Streitkräfte nachführen das sind
die wesentlichen Variablen jetzt kann
man natürlich sagen es kommt dazu dass
noch weitere Streitkräfte zugeführt
werden die bei der russischen
Streitkräfte kommen dazu dann merkt es
anderes sein wir sehen aber gleichzeitig
auch dass die Gegenwehr immer stärker
wird auf der einen Seite und Russland
sich überlegen muss ob es tatsächlich in
die Metropolen einsteigt was dann ganz
andere Art von Konflikt ist was auch mit
sehr viel höheren Verlusten bei den
Streitkräften dann hergehen wird Frau
Sasse jetzt haben wir gehört also es
könnte sein in zwei Wochen kommt es zu
einem Stillstand das wäre dann
vielleicht nicht mehr so einfach für
Putin seine Kriegsziele zu erreichen wie
stark sehen Sie denn dafür eine Chance
in Russland dass es dann tatsächlich
dazu kommt dass eben ist keine
Möglichkeit gibt diese Ziele mehr zu
erreichen ist es dann vielleicht die
Chance die Gesprächskanäle zu Putin
offenzuhalten ihn darüber zu bewegen
dass dieser Krieg aufhört
es laufen ja auf verschiedenen Ebenen
Verhandlungen und sie Stocken und sie
kommen nicht voran weil insbesondere die
russische Seite momentan noch nicht zu
ernsthaften Verhandlungen bereit zu sein
scheint aber wir sehen dass ich der Ton
auch auf der russischen Seite etwas
verändert und zumindest sind die
Verhandlungen die auch zwischen
ukrainischer und russische Seite direkt
stattfinden durch eine sogenannte von
den Verhandlungspartnern als
handlungsparteien als technische Pause
bezeichnete Unterbrechung sofort
fortgesetzt worden das heißt es scheint
etwas konkreter in diesen Verhandlungen
zu werden und das kann man ja vielleicht
ganz ganz vorsichtig optimistisch
zumindest so auslegen dass es um
Waffenstillstandsverhandlungen geht bei
den eigentlichen Forderungen in diesen
Verhandlungen ist man nach wie vor
soweit auseinander das ist bisher schwer
vorstellbar ist dass man in einem
zweiwöchigen Rahmen zu konkreten
Verhandlungsergebnissen kommen wird
herrling noch mal an Sie die Frage gibt
es denn die Möglichkeit das Putin
überhaupt einlenkt ohne sein Gesicht zu
verlieren
das kann ich ihnen einfach nicht sagen
ich glaube das hängt von von
Druckpunkten für Putin aktivier oder die
ich zumindest nicht kenne also was muss
er denn eigentlich erreichen was muss er
zu Hause abliefern kann er das seine
Angriffskrieg den er als
spezialoperation begonnen hat oder ihn
zumindest so nennt kann er da einfach zu
Hause sagen die Operation ist
erfolgreich abgeschlossen und damit ist
es beendet oder aber muss er tatsächlich
mindestens Kiew eingenommen haben um
seine politischen Ziele eigentlich
erreicht zu haben das kann ich Ihnen
nicht sagen klar ist aber auch dass die
militärische Situation irgendwann
zwingend sein wird wenn beide
Streitkräfte keine ländliche
Geländegewinne mehr machen können und es
nur noch Verluste auf beiden Seiten gibt
dann ist so eine Art von
kombinationspunkt erreicht ab da wird es
wahrscheinlich mit den Verhandlungen
einfacher werden aber ganz klar das wird
ein hoher Blut Zoll vorher werden sagen
Herr Mölling und Frau Sasse vielen Dank
für die Einordnung
[Musik]